la scène est devenue familière à Toronto
encore aujourd'hui les citoyens se
réveillent avec une intersection en
rubanée de jaune cette fois-ci la
fusillade a fait deux blessés en plein
centre-ville
un homme et une femme ont été
transportés d'urgence à l'hôpital mais
on ne craint plus pour leur vie quelques
objets qui jonchent le sol permettent
d'imaginer un sauve qui peut général
c'est président du quartier a entendu
les coups de feu en matinée elles sont
maintenant à déménager pour mettre à
l'abri son nouveau-né
par les coups de feu il réclame une
présence policière renforcée si les
Torontois ont l'habitude des incidents
violents le début de juillet semble
particulièrement agité cette année
la semaine dernière une attaque au
couteau dans une rame de métro en
mouvement a créé une scène de panique
le lendemain en plein jour une balle
perdue tuait une passante dans le
quartier la civil le nombre de crimes
majeurs a explosé depuis le début de
l'année 2023 une augmentation de plus de
20% par rapport à la même période l'an
dernier les agressions les vols de
voiture et les entrées par effraction
sont plus fréquentes qu'en 2022 seul le
nombre de domicile a reculé jusqu'ici
n'a pas l'intention d'ajouter des agents
sur le terrain elle mise plutôt sur la
désescalade de la violence avec une plus
grande place laissée aux intervenants
communautaires
pour cette activité la solution passe
avant tout par une meilleure
collaboration entre policiers et
organismes de prévention
ils croient par exemple que les
programmes d'intervention auprès des
jeunes doivent être bonifiées et
rapidement parce que la pression
commence à monter sur l'administration
municipale et torontoivent l'obtenir des
résultats pour vivre paisiblement sans
violence à répétition ici Mathieu Simard
Radio-Canada Toronto